notre émission spéciale elle continue
évidemment consacré toujours à cette
première journée d'examen de la réforme
des retraites alors je vous propose
maintenant un focus en images sur la
stratégie de la gauche sénatoriale pas
de France insoumise ici on l'a dit mais
une volonté affirmée de s'opposer au
texte sur le fond il y a un effet
la nups n'existe pas au Sénat mais si le
gouvernement tablait sur cette absence
pour faire voter la réforme la gauche
entend bien douche et ses espoirs et
dans les starting blocks ça va être
puissant je vous le dis ça va être
puissant les représentants des trois
groupes socialistes communistes et
écologistes ont affiché leur unité nous
voulons faire front déterminer contre
cette réforme que nous qualifions de
réforme de régression sociale nous
allons nous battre dans le détail la
chef de groupe communiste mettant avant
une stratégie en deux temps d'abord
parvenir un débat puis un vote sur
l'article 7 qui porte le report de l'âge
légal ensuite la sénatrice n'exclut pas
d'agir pour faire obstacle à l'adoption
finale de la réforme
faut pas les oublier le 8 9 le 10 il y a
des choses quand même aussi très
importantes les femmes les accompagnants
les enfin bon bref et
nous sommes je crois d'accord sur le
fait de ne pas arriver au bout de
l'examen de ce de ce texte voilà une
stratégie différente de celle mise en
oeuvre à l'Assemblée l'obstruction de la
gauche avait tellement ralenti les
débats que l'examen s'est arrêté à
l'article 2 dans un projet qui en compte
20 côté socialiste on confirme cette
tactique tout en subtilité faire
obstruction comme nos collègues de
l'Assemblée non clairement nous ce que
nous voulons c'est la discussion de tous
les articles mais discuter jusqu'au bout
sans obtenir un vote final ça paraît
possible côté calendrier la gauche
souhaite que le vote de l'article 7
interviennent après la journée de
mobilisation du 7 mars une manière de
faire monter la pression sur la majorité
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de notre second débat
lexagèrement bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
président du cercle de réflexion France
audacieuse Benjamin Morel bonsoir
constitutionnalisme maître de conférence
en droit public à Paris de Panthéon
Assas et vous publiez ce livre la France
en miettes ou aux éditions du Cerf
Benjamin Coriat bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous professeur émérite de
sciences économiques à l'université
Sorbonne Paris Nord et évidemment
Mathieu croissanto est resté à mes côtés
je commence puisqu'on vient de voir le
sujet de Yann sur la stratégie des des
trois parties de gauche au Sénat à
l'extérieur que change l'absence
d'insoumis ici profondément ça change
beaucoup de choses ça change un
rééquilibrage en fait plus traditionnel
avec un pôle de gouvernement de gauche
de gouvernement en tout cas d'approche
de gouvernement avec un pôle de droite
aussi de gouvernement on espère avoir
des débats évidemment plus sobre plus
consensuel mais au-delà de ça je crois
que le plus important c'est que quand
vous avez un gouvernement qui propose un
texte le rôle du Parlement le rôle de la
démocratie c'est évidemment de débattre
pour être aussi le reflet de ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur du Parlement mais le
débat ne suffit pas c'est pour adopter
et améliorer le texte c'est ça le
travail des parlementaires
parce que alors oui c'est ce sont des
mots assez durs parce que
l'échange des idées et même les
confrontations d'idées me paraissent
très saines mais je trouve que quand on
a une responsabilité en tant qu'élu
c'est aussi d'exercer ses fonctions avec
dignité et c'est quelque chose moi en
tant que en tant que concitoyenne que je
n'ai pas aimé voir quel que soit les
dérives et pas que pour la France
insoumise j'estime que le le la
représentation au Parlement doit se
faire avec un minimum de sérénité parce
que oui je trouve que c'est bien que le
Sénat se projette en se disant que sur
les 20 articles ils iront au bout de
l'analyse et que se dire que l'Assemblée
nationale n'a vu que deux articles sur
20 c'est pas quelque chose qui en tant
que citoyenne je trouve et rassurante
est-ce que vous êtes aussi critique sur
ce qui s'est passé à l'assemb non non
j'ai pas du tout été ravi par le
spectacle de l'Assemblée nationale et je
suis pas parlementaire donc je sais pas
du tout quelle attitude personnellement
j'aurais eu mais ce qui doit nuancer ce
qui a été dit c'est que
on a voulu faire tenir un débat dans
deux limites absolues la première limite
c'est C 64 ans c'est 43 ans circulait il
y a rien à voir à l'intérieur de ça on
peut toujours discuter alors que en gros
70% de la population
rejettent ça donc les parlementaires il
était de leurs devoir de trouver un
moyen de faire savoir que ce débat là
était pipé et que c'était pas celui-là
qu'il fallait avoir donc ça c'est la
première limite et la deuxième limite
c'est que on a utilisé une procédure
donc on a un constitutionnaliste parmi
nous donc je vais surtout pas faire la
leçon une procédure très accélérée qui
faisait que un véritable au fond de
toute façon pouvait pas avoir lieu en
tout cas dans un temps aussi les 50
jours au total pour les deux assemblées
oui mais enfin pour pour chacune des
assemblées ça fait ça fait assez peu par
rapport au procès dur normal donc
comme tous les Français je me suis pas
du tout réjoui de ce de ce mais comment
dire voilà cette double limite faisait
que de toute façon le vrai débat
n'aurait pas eu lieu
on peut peut-être le rappeler parce
qu'on fait comme si tout le monde était
au courant mais on est dans
effectivement dans un véhicule
parlementaire original on l'a déjà dit
ici mais je veux bien que vous nous
l'aurez expliqué original baroque en
tout cas c'est à dire qu'on a affaire à
un bel un projet de loi de financement
éducatif de la sécurité sociale donc qui
normalement est fait pour modifier votre
budget de la Sécu au cours d'une année
l'objectif et bien dans une période où
les troubles sociaux ou les troubles des
comptes sociaux vont être mis en jeu et
bien c'est de rééquilibrer le budget
assez rapidement en vue de l'année et
explique les 50 jours exactement
50 jours il faut aller rapidement et en
effet on n'a jamais utilisé ce type de
véhicule pour une réforme de fond sur
les retraites ça pose plusieurs sujets
de constitutionnalité sur ce qu'on va
pouvoir mettre dans cette réforme ce
qu'on appelle les cavaliers sociaux
l'index seniors la pénibilité voire
éventuellement certains éléments qui
sera introduits au Sénat comme certains
régimes spéciaux tout ça interroge quand
à la consonnalité ça interroge également
quand à la consumérité de la procédure
et là on a vu que le Conseil d'État
renacle est un petit peu parce que
normalement ce projet le bâtiment la
sécurité sociale il concerne les comptes
de l'année et ce qui seront vraiment
réellement impactés par la réforme c'est
pas évident par ailleurs on a un
véhicule qui pour les raisons qui ont
été évoquées les raisons d'aider et sont
pas réellement idoine et c'est important
pour comprendre l'obstruction que va
faire parce qu'on pourrait nommer
obstruction de la part de la gauche
nattoriale l'objectif il est double il
est d'un côté de fragiliser la
légitimité de cette réforme en disant
mais cette réforme elle a été votée par
personne ni par l'Assemblée en première
lecture ni par le Sénat non plus et ça
ne sera voté quand votre final donc là
faire en sorte que qu'on n'aille pas au
bout de l'examen
discuter discuter et discuter mais
discuter tous les articles autant que
faire ce peu mais ne pas voter au final
pour fragiliser la légitimité mais
également la consonnalité parce qu'en
effet la procédure elle est à la fois
baroque pas faite pour ça et le
gouvernement la quelque peu tiraillé de
tous les côtés et donc ce faisant pour
le Conseil constitutionnel il peut y
avoir des vérités sinon de tous censurer
au moins de jouer un petit peu et bien à
la mitraillette avec les articles moi je
me pose une question est-ce qu'on a déjà
vu au-delà de la procédure de 47,1 qui
était pas très connu et qui
effectivement d'habitude est faite pour
pour rentrer dans les clous le plus vite
avant la fin de l'année civile pour que
les comptes soient voilà est-ce qu'on a
déjà vu une loi non votée à l'Assemblée
non votée au Sénat échafauder en
conditions mix paritaire
et présenter ensuite au vote des deux
assemblées à votre finale la réponse est
non parce qu'en fait seuls les projets
de loi de finances et les projets de
bâtiments de la sécurité sociale pas
depuis longtemps il faut voir que le 47
tirints tel qu'on le connaît il date en
fait de 96 donc on a quelque chose une
disposition relativement récente d'un
point de vue constitutionnel et en règle
générale pour les budgets ça pose pas de
problème c'est à dire que on peut avoir
des budgets qui éventuellement ne sont
pas votés par le Sénat on peut avoir
mais en règle générale les délais sont
relativement bien respectés parce que
tout le monde sait qu'il faut que le
budget soit adopté au 1er janvier sinon
il y a des ordonnances donc ce faisant
là on est vraiment face à quelque chose
d'assez inédit on a un véhicule
législatif qui n'a pas vraiment été
pensé pour ce type de texte d'où le fait
et bien qu'on marche totalement dans
l'inconnu et que bah ça pose beaucoup
beaucoup de questions deuxième question
si jamais le texte n'était ni adopté à
votre final à l'Assemblée ni adopter en
votre final au Sénat le gouvernement
peut le l'exécutif peut le passer par
ordonnance alors s'il y a rejet non
c'est à dire que
les ordonnances ne valent que si jamais
vous atteignez la limite de 50 jours et
que le texte n'a pas été voté
définitivement mais il faut voir que
passer le texte par ordonnance si jamais
on devait arriver à la limite de 50
jours et pas une obligation pour le
gouvernement c'est à dire qu'il peut
laisser traîner un peu plus le temps ça
reste une possibilité et au vu du texte
il est assez peu probable qu'on arrive
aux ordonnances et tout ça pour arriver
peut-être par un Conseil constitutionnel
on verra bien bref voilà tout ça pour ça
Alexia m'en voulait intervenir oui pour
rappeler quand même aussi que du point
de vue plus politique
surtout la gauche déjà à l'Assemblée
nationale il y avait eu un débat et là
pour le Sénat veut aussi arriver quand
même à montrer le positionnement de
chacun des partis politiques sur chacun
des articles alors on parle beaucoup de
l'article 7 sur le recul de 60 ans c'est
le plus emblématique pour pour y voir
clair et ce que je trouve assez
intéressant c'est que là on va retrouver
quelque part un peu de clarté parce que
il y a une bipolarité qui s'installe à
nouveau au niveau du Sénat alors que au
au niveau de l'Assemblée nationale il y
avait eu des mélanges un peu baroques
pour reprendre votre expression au
niveau des accords sur certains
amendements et là quelque part ce qui
est intéressant et qui peut peut-être
faire que les Français
regardent avec intérêt ce qui se passe
dans l'examen au Sénat c'est qu'on va
avoir une vision en espère un peu plus
clair du positionnement politique réel
de chacune de chacun des pôles au fur et
à mesure sur chacun des sous sujets en
fait de ce texte
sénatoriale pour les trois parties de
gauche représentée ici au Sénat ah oui
certainement certainement je veux dire
je crois que les épisodes du débat au
Parlement
d'une certaine manière marquer les
esprits on l'oubliera mais en tout cas
pour le moment c'est présent alors après
la difficulté ça bien ça a bien été dit
la difficulté pour pour la gauche du qui
est pas exactement la même que celle du
Parlement c'est qu'ils ont la même
opposition au fond ils veulent pas de
cette loi bon mais néanmoins il faut le
dire différemment oui voilà néanmoins
ils veulent quand même la discuter mais
ils veulent pas la voter donc je vais
dire il va falloir qu'il la joue fine si
je peux si je peux me permettre
effectivement allez on va parler du de
cette date du 7 mars qui est évidemment
dans dans tous les esprits vous l'avez
compris la volonté des des trois parties
de gauche c'est de d'attendre la journée
de grève nationale pour débattre de
l'article 7 c'est ce que disait ce matin
Patrick Kanner président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat chez nos confrères
de Sud Radio je confirme votre micro
pour nos auditeurs que l'article 7 qui
est l'article essentiel c'est l'article
pour lequel cette réforme a été bâtie à
savoir le report de l'âge légal de de
deux ans de 62 à 64 ans alors c'est tout
ça il sera débattu nous allons faire
nous nous contre propositions pour
montrer qu'il est inutile c'est
d'article 7 qu'il est injuste et il sera
voté parce que malheureusement il sera
voté par la droite sanatoriale soutenue
par une partie du centre et de la droite
macroniste donc clairement nous savons
face of miracle je veux bien mettre un
siège mais l'article 7 sera voté nous
notre intérêt c'est que l'article va
voter avant la mobilisation du 7 mars ou
pas après après ah oui la question de
voter avant la mobilisation du 7 mars
que l'article 7 sera éclairé par la
mobilisation du 7 mars parce que bien
évidemment si dans le 7 mars il y a 2
millions de personnes dans la rue si les
services publics sont à l'arrêt si les
entreprises connaissent aussi une grève
importante et bien ça sera un signe
donné par le peuple français par nos
concitoyens au gouvernement et donc
aussi au Parlement pour dire cet article
7 on en veut pas avec ça j'ai vraiment
sur la capillarité finalement entre
la rue la puissance d'une journée de
manifestation et de blocage et
les débats dans une assemblée comme
comme le Sénat est-ce que vous pensez
que les sénateurs peuvent être infl
commencer par on verra bien mais la
puissance d'une journée de mobilisation
ou de plusieurs journées de mobilisation
c'est éventuellement l'influence de
quelques sénateurs centrices notamment
sur lesquels il pourrait y avoir un
petit peu de un petit peu de bouger
comme on dit
d'abord un point qui me paraît très
important c'est que il y a un constat
c'est que la mobilisation est très forte
que les Français sont effectivement
très opposés à cette réforme et ça je
crois qu'il faut l'entendre on a vu
alors par intermittence mais il y a eu
quand même beaucoup de monde y compris
dans toute la France dans la rue et que
ça c'est une opposition forte qui par
capillarité se retrouve jusqu'en
hautement en discussion enfin éclair les
débats et on voit bien l'importance pour
la gauche mais pas que pour la gauche
mais pour les LR aussi et pour les LR
parce que on parle souvent de de sucré
et de Salé dans une réforme des comme
celle-là les on a vu des LR un peu à
contre emploi essayer d'adoucir le texte
sans doute
donc cette notion de capillarité elle
marche dans les dans les deux sens et
elle vient éclairer elle vient éclairer
les débats après est-ce que ça peut
faire en bout de course reculer le
gouvernement parce que c'est la
troisième question
ça je ne le pense pas je ne le pense pas
parce que l'enjeu est trop fort et en
prenant un petit peu de recul je crois
que c'est important d'arriver à réformer
le pays pour ces sujets là parce que sur
le fond peut-être qu'on a des
divergences mais sur le fond la question
de la démographie elle est centrale et
ce sont des chiffres enfin ce sont des
des constats là aussi qui doivent être
respectés c'est-à-dire qu'on est
aujourd'hui face à une diminution devant
nous du nombre d'actifs on a déjà là
elle est déjà là mais pour l'équilibre
du système si on veut garder plus de
justice sociale et bien dans le il faut
un peu plus de travail bon et ça dit de
façon non agressive mais le plus le plus
consensuel possible je crois que c'est
important de le rappeler aux Français et
je finis juste par quelque chose c'est
que vous voyez j'ai été très frappé moi
par ces deux années de crise qu'on a
vécu où les Français se sont beaucoup
offusqué du manque soi-disant de
prévisible de prévisions de la classe
politique sur les grandes les grands
sujets qui étaient à traiter et bien là
on a un grand sujet qui est à traiter et
quelque part je trouve que on peut pas
demander tout et son contraire et que ce
serait bien d'arriver à prendre des
décisions fortes Benjamin Coriat cet
argument effectivement de la démographie
on pourrait considérer qu'il est
imparable et pourtant cette réforme elle
reste majoritairement rejetée par les
Français non mais il est parable
doublement il est pas le doublement il y
a eu un éminent
démographes qui a fait un papier dans le
monde voilà en l'occurrence en
expliquant que les hypothèses
démographiques du corps qui par ailleurs
fait un travail tout à fait remarquable
d'orientation des retours voilà du
Conseil d'orientation sont un peu
indigentes sont un peu indigentes et que
en particulier il y a deux facteurs qui
n'ont pas été pris en compte le taux de
mortalité n'est pas du tout probablement
celui qui a été retenu par le corps
d'une part et d'autre part la natalité
immigrée surtout sur une très longue
période de de 30 ou 40 ans comme comme
comme on le voit dans dans les scénarios
du corps avec donc les déplacements liés
au changement climatique etc aurait
mérité des hypothèses beaucoup plus
sérieuses bon donc c'est tout à fait
parable de ce côté là si je peux dire il
y a rien d'indubitable dans les
hypothèses que la tendance à voir le
nombre d'actifs voilà
pour payer les retraites de plus en plus
nombreuses ça cette tendance elle peut
s'inverser ou en tout cas ce tempérer se
tempérer avec des hypothèses
démographiques tout à fait raisonnable
sur lequel le corps n'est pas rentré
jusqu'à présent mais dans lequel dans
lequel sans doute dans les années qui
viennent il viendra bon donc il y a il y
a cet élément là en plus si vous voulez
l'élément clé en vérité c'est la
productivité bon par ailleurs c'est
parable si je peux dire par rapport à ce
que à ce que vous disiez par le fait que
on l'a on l'a beaucoup dit répéter il
s'agit de somme relativement faible
celle du déficit par rapport
12 13 milliards
exactement on peut les trouver de 36
manières sans imposer un impôt de deux
ans de vie supplémentaire donc je veux
dire
le sens de la prévision dont fait preuve
le gouvernement là-dessus franchement
c'est extrêmement discutable d'autant
que il faut se souvenir qu'il y a un an
c'était le régime par point c'était tout
à fait indispensable etc et avec la même
improvisation maintenant on nous dit non
c'est deux ans de plus donc je veux dire
il y a vraiment je sais pas s'il y avait
autant d'improvisation il y a en
l'occurrence c'était 2019 la réforme
précédente qui avait pris un long temps
de discussion et de et de négociation de
mener pas voilà par exemple de loi mais
bon on a entendu vos arguments aux
autres là-dessus
c'est une partie du débat quand même il
faut revenir au fond de la réforme de
temps en temps mais je voudrais qu'on
vienne au rôle du Sénat et je vais
proposer à Mathias Arès de nous
rejoindre tout de suite parce que
pendant ces quelques jours c'est presque
deux semaines de débat rebonsoir Mathias
évidemment le Seigneur va être sous le
feu des projecteurs il y a plusieurs
personnalités plusieurs sénateurs et
sénatrices il va falloir suivre
absolument une médiatisation subite qui
n'est pas sans rappeler par exemple en
2018 la commission autour de la faire
Benalla qui avait mise en lumière les
sénateurs philiba ou jean-Pierre Sueur
c'est un peu de choses près la même
situation qui devrait t'attendre les
élus de la Chambre haute cette fois une
médiatisation mesurée car dans chaque
groupe politique de la Haute Assemblée
les élus sont tous d'accord sur au moins
un point il ne veulent pas imiter leur
collègue députés par des invectives ou
des coups d'éclat il promettent un débat
de fond notre rédaction a donc préparé
une liste de 10 sénatrices et sénateurs
à suivre pendant ces débats parmi
ceux-ci il y en a qui se démarqueront
par leur soutien à la réforme et
d'autres qui seront opposés alors on
commence par ceux qui sont favorables à
la réforme et bien Bruno Retailleau
c'est le président du groupe LR le
sénateur devant des déclarer début
janvier cette réforme c'est notre
réforme en rappelant que le report de
l'âge de départ est voté depuis
plusieurs années au Sénat il nuance
toutefois son soutien le gouvernement
n'aura pas leur aval sans mesure forte
pour les maires de famille il y a
également Hervé Marseille président du
groupe centriste c'est l'autre pilier de
la majorité sénatoriales et l'adoption
des textes dépend de son entente avec
les LR favorables à la réforme les
centristes souhaitent toutefois aller
plus loin sur l'emploi des seniors
notamment avec un système de bonus malus
il y a également René Paul Savary c'est
le monsieur retraite des républicains au
Sénat le sénateur de la Marne est membre
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
sera le rapporteur du texte et puis
pêle-mêle on peut citer Catherine de
roche présidentelle de la commission des
affaires sociales et les abeilles
Doisneau centrist et spécialistes des
questions de santé ou encore François
Patriat président du groupe Renaissance
et fidèle parmi les fidèles du président
de la République allez on fait la liste
de ceux qui sont contre maintenant ils
sont tous sans surprise
issus de l'aile gauche de l'hémicycle le
premier d'entre eux Patrick Kanner
président du groupe socialiste il est
l'un des farouches opposants à la
réforme des retraites les luttes du Nord
a fait savoir qu'il était déterminé à
utiliser toutes les procédures pour que
le 12 mars au soir date limite des
débats le texte ne soit pas adopté il y
a Eliana président du groupe CRCE
habitué des projecteurs depuis sa
retentissante commission d'enquête sur
les cabinets de conseils les lieux
communiste n'en est pas à sa première
opposition à la réforme des retraites en
2010 son groupe politique avait
multiplié les actions en dedans et en
dehors de l'hémicycle pour s'opposer à
la réforme verte enfin il faut citer le
chef de fil des écologistes et sénateurs
de l'Isère Guillaume Gontard ou encore
la madame retraite du groupe socialiste
au Sénat Monique Lubin pour plus de
détails vous pouvez retrouver l'article
détaillé de notre collègue Simon
barbarie sur www.publicaina.fr merci
beaucoup Mathias Benjamin Morel qui veut
vraiment aller au bout du texte là on a
fait on a dressé une sorte de panorama
des groupes politiques et des
personnalités qui vont émerger dans ces
au sein de ces groupes politiques qui
veut vraiment aller au bout du texte
alors la droite va aller au bout du
texte et la présidence et le groupe
Renaissance alors allez au bout du texte
de pas dire adopter le texte en l'état
c'est à dire qu'on voit que tout à
l'heure vous se poser la question est-ce
que vraiment et bien il peut y avoir une
pression de la rue sur le Sénat regardez
c'est passé tout à l'heure c'est à dire
que tout à l'heure il y a eu des motion
d'y recevabilité la droite a voté contre
la gauche a voté pour ça c'est partager
de manière à peu près parfaite et donc
on peut penser que tout au long de
l'examen ça va être simple demain
les parties de gauche et il devrait se
passer la même chose voilà on a on
devrait pas avoir de frontière ou comme
on a pu en avoir à l'Assemblée nationale
en revanche il va y avoir un jeu c'est à
dire que quand vous regardez ce que
propose notamment la droite Bruno
Retailleau et ben vous avez par exemple
tout un volet sur les régimes spéciaux
qui a priori devait être devrait être
mis en avant ça n'arrange pas vraiment
le gouvernement à la veille d'une
mobilisation générale où il peut y avoir
des blocages qui justement concernent
ces professions qui ont une capacité de
blocage je pense que le gouvernement ce
serait bien passé des amendements du
groupe LR sur ce sujet donc on voit que
là-dessus LR joue son propre jeu et que
infini là le la loi qui va être votée et
bien au Sénat le sera aux conditions de
LR si jamais on arrive au bout ensuite
en commission mixte paritaire plus de
parlementaires LR et son triste qu'il
n'y a de ensemble il faut bien
comprendre que la CMP se conclave entre
7 députés cette sénateurs va proposer la
mouture finale qui ensuite et bien sera
soumis aux député si cette mouture elle
est aux conditions de LR à au Sénat et
si cette mouture elle est très dure il
est pas certain qu'il y a une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale pour la voter et
s'il y a pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale pour la beauté ça veut dire 49
alinéa 3 ou gouvernement dans la panade
donc on voit que le jeu aujourd'hui de
LR et le jeu du gouvernement
apparaissent se corréler mais que
derrière et bien un soutien affiché à la
réforme il y a des enjeux politiques qui
ne sont pas forcément raccords entre
d'un côté Matignon et de l'autre le
groupe LR au Sénat
si on focus sur la famille macroniste là
aussi il y a des sensibilités
différentes les cousins horizons que
vous connaissez bien ils sont surtout
sensibles à quel aspect de cette réforme
l'équilibre budgétaire l'équilibre
budgétaire et je pense c'est à dire que
on est dans une logique de mémoire
Édouard Philippe avait assez bien assez
bien expliqué quand il avait été
interviewé sur le sujet puisque c'est
ces prises de parole sont assez rares
de mémoire si vous voulez
la discussion est toujours la bienvenue
dès lors que on ne remet pas en cause en
fait l'équilibre budgétaire et c'est
tout le sujet on voit que par exemple
évidemment avec les marqueurs LR qui
sont assez fort notamment sur la surcote
des pensions pour les maires de famille
bon très bien mais en face il faut
mettre un chiffre des 300 millions ça
vient 300 millions potentiellement donc
je crois que le c'est vrai qu'il y a des
il y a des prismes des angles un petit
peu différents au sein de au sein de la
majorité et je crois que ce qu'on peut
retenir c'est que vraiment l'équilibre
l'ordre dans les contes est un sujet qui
est important pour une des composantes
de cette majorité une chose est sûre
Mathieu c'est que ça n'a pas toujours
été facile pour les sénateurs publics
plus globalement les parlementaires
macronistes de défense celles ouais il y
a eu quelques quoi alors vous allez
revenir sur l'affaire de la retraite à
1200 euros qui est colle au gouvernement
comme le sparadrap du capitaine
c'est l'histoire du sucré et du salé en
fait c'est un bonbon sucré qui est
devenu un bouffable notamment et donc
c'est une terrible erreur de la part du
gouvernement pour se souvenir en fait
vous souvenez campagne présidentielle
Emmanuel Macron promet une retraite
minimale à 1100 euros puis ensuite il
annonce la réforme des retraites à
l'automne et puis Elisabeth band demande
du temps pour négocier et puis elle sort
de ce temps pour négocier en présentant
sa réforme et là la retraite est devenue
1200 euros donc il y a quel on a déjà
gagné 100 euros et puis donc on comprend
que c'est une retraite minimale c'est
l'argument qui est développé martelé par
le gouvernement pour faire passer la
pilule de sa réforme des retraites c'est
l'autre jambe du M du et en même temps
voilà c'est oui le coup du coup de bâton
et puis ça c'est ça va plus vite et puis
elle dit je vais d'abord une vie de
travail doit garantir une retraite digne
on a même compris deux jours plus tard
après la présentation
deux jours plus tard hier soir les les
les représentants de du parti LR donc
rxiotti Bruno Retailleau vous vous
souvenez et puis Olivier Marleix de
l'Assemblée le patron des députés et là
on apprend que ça va toucher non
seulement les futurs retraités mais les
retraités actuels et donc on se dit bon
ben c'est peut-être pas si mal cette
affaire là et puis en fait patatra c'est
là que ça commence c'est pas si simple
parce que dans les faits je vois pas
venir sur les détails de du
fonctionnement du minimum contributif
parce que sinon tous les téléspectateurs
vont partir en courant mais en gros on a
compris le gouvernement
avait laissé entendre en tout cas que
c'était un petit peu pour tout le monde
mais on a compris que c'était pas pour
tout le monde évidemment que c'était
pour les carrières complètes or toujours
compliqué d'avoir une carrière complète
c'est pas la majorité surtout à des
niveaux de salaire qui sont assez bas on
a plutôt des carrières hachées que
c'était évidemment à temps plein et non
pas à temps partiel parce que voilà et
puis que c'était pour des salariés qui
avaient vécu toute leur vie au niveau du
SMIC et là non plus ils sont pas parce
que c'est rare de trouver quelqu'un qui
commence et qui finit au SMIC toute sa
carrière résultat des courses alors il y
avait des chiffres
le gouvernement au début certains donc
laissez entendre ils ont pas clairement
il faut être honnête personne n'a dit ça
sera pour tout le monde mais ils ont
tous l'été planer cette ambiguïté parce
qu'après tout c'était pas si mal le
chiffre de 200000 a circulé et puis
pousser dans ses retranchements Olivier
du stop tu as dû finir par sortir un
chiffre et il a sorti 40000 ce qui fait
déjà une sacrée diminution par rapport à
ce qu'on imaginait tout le monde de
100000 40000 et puis ça encore c'était
jusqu'à avant-hier parce que là
aujourd'hui on a le chiffre des
bénéficiaires là c'est devenu de la main
du ministre dans une lettre envoyée au
député Jérôme Guedj qui lui posait la
question et là c'est 10 à 20 000
personnes par génération alors on a
envie de dire tant mieux pour elle mais
on a quand même loin de ce qu'imaginer
beaucoup de futurs et actuels retraités
et encore cette concession il a fallu
lui arracher on en a parlé sur ce
plateau mais Jérôme Guedj agit en tant
que co-président de la mission
develation des contes de la Sécu il est
allé à la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale pour contrôler sur place et sur
pièce comme on dit les éléments qui
avaient pu permettre à Olivier du socle
d'avancer le chiffre de 40000 il est
revenu bredouille parce que ça venait
pas d'ici et donc c'est pour ça que le
ministre a dû faire tourner les machines
de ses propres services et qui a sorti
ce chiffre de 10 ans qu'il a été obligé
de répondre
pour le gouvernement oui c'est un
vraiment un coup dur parce que ça donne
non seulement l'impression aux français
qu'on a voulu les tromper d'une certaine
façon mais aussi ça traduit une chose
c'est que cette réforme elle est
incroyablement brouillonne elle a été
faite à la hussarde sur un coin de table
et on découvre plein de plein de manque
plein de trous dans la raquette ça c'est
c'est quand même assez ahurissant et
puis surtout ça prive définitivement un
coup dur pour le gouvernement ça a privé
définitivement le gouvernement de son
argument fétiche celui de la justice de
sa réforme qui était vendue le
gouvernement fait dans cette affaire a
perdu sa deuxième jambe du et en même
temps Benjamin Coriat allez on disait
qu'avec Elisabeth borne et Olivier du
soft on a on avait on donner deux
techniciens qui maîtrisaient leur
réforme jusque dans les moindres détails
donc ça veut dire quoi on s'était trompé
une réforme des retraites de toute façon
c'est toujours très compliqué donc c'est
normal qui est comme dit souvent Mathieu
des trous dans la raquette comment vous
l'analysez ça moi je l'analyse bon
d'abord c'est toujours très compliqué il
y a toujours des sailles des fêtes comme
on dit un peu un peu inattendu donc je
veux dire on peut pas on peut pas
reprocher de pas avoir une complète
maîtrise ce que vous avez montré c'est
que on est très très loin de la complète
maîtrise mais je veux dire il y a
toujours des il y a toujours des des
effets secondaires de ce type bon
simplement moi je je j'explique tous ces
quacks et tous ces problèmes par le fait
que le choix c'était 64 ans plus
l'accélération du passage à 43 ans donc
ça c'était sûr et certain et donc à
partir de là une fois qu'ils ont fixé ça
ils ont commencé à faire de la couture
et je pense que il y a des choses qu'ils
ont prévu puis il y a des choses il y a
des choses qui découvrent au fur et à
mesure et vous l'avez très bien montré
je crois pour faire passer les normalité
de deux ans d'impôts de travail
supplémentaire on a on avait imaginé
cette histoire des 1200 euros et puis
c'est avéré sans doute il se doutait que
ça ne pouvait pas avoir l'impact
massif qu'on pouvait imaginer mais sans
doute l'imaginait-il pas que ça serait
aussi rikiki donc moi voilà c'est comme
ça que j'explique j'explique par le fait
que ce qui était vraiment voulu c'était
64 ans passage à 43 ans accéléré et que
du coup
sous cette sous cette sous cette
détermination là on découvre toute une
série de trucs avec lesquels on essaye
de jouer plus ou moins bien et pas très
bien et c'est vrai que bon le dernier le
dernier coup de griffe si j'ose dire de
Monsieur Retailleau c'est très sérieux
quand même c'est très sérieux c'est à
dire essayez de demander que
on abandonne la cause du grand-père et
que des gens qui se sont engagés dans
des carrières là on parle des régimes
spéciaux voilà on parle Virgin spéciaux
sous des conditions très particulières à
mi-chemin on leur dit ben non c'est fini
c'est un peu énorme donc on se demande à
quoi il joue hein
bien sûr
c'était ça moi j'ai commencé le boulot
parce que dans le cas des régimes
spéciaux ils sont pas spéciaux pour rien
c'est en général
il y a une pénibilité etc il y avait des
jeux de compensation sur lesquels on
peut discuter mais en tout cas c'est
cela qui était fixé il y a où il y avait
une pénibilité votre avis là-dessus avec
sa Germain je pense que chaque métier
évolue qu'il y a des vrais pénibilités
qu'il faut prendre qu'il faut prendre en
compte très nettement d'autres qui ne
sont plus d'actualité aujourd'hui je moi
je ne suis pas pour indépendamment des
positionnements politiques c'est ma
vision d'avocat c'est de ne pas remettre
en cause un contrat en l'exécution voilà
donc vous êtes favorable à la clause du
grand-père c'est à dire que la
suppression des régimes spéciaux dans
toutes les deux concernera que les
nouveaux entrants à la RATP ou chez EDF
que ceux qui sont principalement
concernés à partir du 1er septembre
c'est ce qui est le domaine du droit en
général quand on fait des réformes
structurelles et qu'on modifie un cadre
juridique en général il y a une clause
de grand-père donc c'est un mécanisme
qui moi mais en tout cas dans ma vie
professionnelle et particulièrement
familier donc je ne suis pas choquée de
le retrouver dans la vie politique alors
vous vous dites c'est peut-être un piège
tendu par Bruno Retailleau et les LR ici
au Sénat on va écouter parce que là la
réponse a été assez rapide de la part du
gouvernement a écouté le porte-parole du
gouvernement oliveran c'était hier à la
sortie du Conseil des ministres
s'agissant des régimes spéciaux nous
sommes là dans la prolongation d'une
action que nous avons commencé il y a
quelques années puisque nous avons mis
fin au régime spécial de la SNCF avec
des modalités qui ont montré leur
efficacité et que nous voulons appliquer
scrupuleusement au régime spéciaux qui
persiste aujourd'hui
Benjamin Morel et LR vont-ils résister à
la tentation de savonner la planche du
gouvernement je pense pas
en donnant l'impression évidemment
qu'ils sont parce que il faut
reconnaître une forme de cohérence à
chaque PLFSS chaque année il vote le
relèvement de l'âge de la retraite et
l'expression de la gestion donc c'est
très très cohérent et pourquoi se
retiendrait-il mais évidemment la veille
d'une grève reconductible 7 c'est très
clairement un cadeau un poisonné fait au
gouvernement mais ça rejoint la question
de la mauvaise préparation parce que
tout de même enfin disait tout à l'heure
2019-2020 c'était bien préparé
souvenez-vous de la vie au vitrioles du
Conseil d'État on a un avis qui rarement
a été aussi violent de la part du
Conseil général j'ai peut-être dit bien
mais en tout cas longuement longuement
mais bien pas vraiment en tout cas selon
le Conseil d'État et ensuite vous avez
toute une procédure derrière qui est
également très erratique l'objectif à
l'époque c'est de dire c'est un peu
technique mais on n'utilise pas le temps
législatif programmé parce que ça va
nous amener aux élections municipales on
n'a pas envie de s'embêter etc et
Charles Ferrandi il y a pas de problème
on va tenir résultat il déclenche un 49
alinéa 3 on l'a oublié parce qu'ensuite
il y a eu la covid la veille d'une
élection municipale ce qui quoi qu'on en
pense politiquement est désastreux donc
on voit que déjà en 2019 2020 il y a
beaucoup d'amateurs
et là on retrouve ça parce que
évidemment il y a ce fond de la réforme
qui est problématique et qui est mal
communiqué et de l'autre côté d'un point
de vue procédural il y a pas que le
sucré lié au 1200 euros la pénibilité
l'index senior je reviens sur mes
obsessions de pensionnats mais a priori
si on en croit les offres de presse de
Laurent Fabius ça passe ou les fourches
codes du Conseil constitutionnel donc ce
sont ce serait des cavaliers sociaux ça
ne passerait pas avoir
hypothèse voilà on a pas de recul c'est
à dire que aucune incidence sur les
comptes de la Sécu voilà exactement
sur le fond sur le fond si vous voulez
il s'agit pas dire que l'index senior en
lui-même est inconscient bien compris il
s'agit de dire que le véhicule
législatif est mauvais et donc si le
lendemain du de l'examen par le Conseil
constitutionnel et bien tout le sucré le
sucré qui restait est enlevé par le
Conseil constitutionnel et qu'il ne
reste que la mère évidemment ça va être
encore plus con difficile au
gouvernement d'essayer de faire le
service après-vente de la réforme donc
là il y a en effet un peu d'amateurisme
procédural Alexia germon sait que les
marqueurs idéologiques parce qu'il y a
des Marguer idéologiques dans une
réforme comme c'est là que les que les
sénateurs et l'air veulent imposer pour
vous c'est quoi
la question de la des femmes et de la
surcote familiale en fait ça c'est le je
pense le premier point
il y a également le maintien à 60 ans de
l'âge de départ en fait pour tout ce qui
est incapacité permanente et je crois
que le gouvernement voudrait 62 ans de
ce point de vue là et puis il y avait
quand même la question autour de
l'emploi des seniors parce que c'est
quelque chose qui parle aussi à
l'électorat bien sûr
LR et là vous voyez par contre moi je
trouve que ça aurait été un moment
formidable aussi pour essayer de
d'inventer
une façon un peu un peu plus audacieuse
pour le coup de voir de quel comment
intégrer les seniors dont on a vraiment
besoin dans les entreprises quand toute
personne qui qui connaît bien le
l'écosystème entrepreneurial on pourrait
très inventif avec un système de
mouvement la
on en est très loin mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que on voit le sujet à
travers le prisme de l'index senior en
disant d'abord c'est uniquement de la
publication et et c'est donc de ce qu'on
appelle en bon français du Naiman shame
ok
l'étape d'après c'était potentiellement
de pouvoir infliger encore quelque chose
de
des pénalités des punitifs donc c'est
pas non plus forcément
la solution alors qu'on pourrait essayer
de construire quelque chose qui soit
véritablement embarquant ou en plus on
remettrait du du lien entre des
générations qui ont besoin d'être
formées encadrés et pas uniquement voir
les choses par le prisme de
l'exonération de cotisation sociale pour
le coup un entreprise puisqu'il propose
le CDI seniors un CDI exonéré de
cotisations
sociales mais après le vrai problème de
ce débat sur les retraites c'est vous
vous avez dit c'est vrai ils étaient sur
les 64 ans et 43 ans mais c'est surtout
qu'on n'a pas eu de débat sur les pistes
de financement bien sûr donc j'ai à
partir du moment où vous écartez de
toute façon de toucher aux pensions des
retraités par électoralisme à partir du
moment où vous écartez de toute façon de
toucher au cotisation et aux impôts par
idéologie bérale mais il reste plus que
le dos des salariés et alors là après
est-ce que c'est 64 63 43 c'est le choix
qui a été fait et celui-là oui oui en
plus cette question des seniors elle est
absolument centrale parce que je veux
dire le taux d'emploi des 60 64 ans
c'est 35%. c'est catastrophique ça veut
dire que on va précipiter dans le
chômage alors il se trouve que hier est
paru
un ensemble d'études sur le bilan de
l'allongement de 60 ans à 62 ans il est
catastrophique on a plongé dans la
précarité l'assistance sociale et le
chômage pratiquement 200 000 personnes
je dis ça de mémoire bon donc là on
recommence avec les 62 64 et alors que
c'est sans doute un des domaines dans
lequel il y avait une action
intelligente de longue durée astucieuse
créative à avoir parce que la solution
elle est là est-ce que propose ce que
propose les LR de mon point de vue c'est
catastrophique c'est-à-dire que un CDI
défiscalisé ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que on prépare encore de nouvelles
crises parce que à chaque fois qu'on
touche au cotisations on creuse le trou
et on prépare de nouveau rendez-vous qui
sont totalement pipés parce qu'il faut
trouver des recettes supplémentaires
alors qu'on les diminue de rendez-vous
en rendez-vous donc on va jamais y
arriver alors on parlait de marquer
idéologique Bruno Retailleau lui il pose
les lignes rouges dans l'écoute
on a que deux lignes rouges les mêmes
familles et l'équilibre financier
l'équilibre financier parce que ça sert
à quoi de faire une réforme si c'est une
réforme qui doit nous conduire à nouveau
à des déséquilibres en 2030 le régime de
la réforme c'est difficile le point
d'arrivée de la réforme ça ne peut pas
être encore et toujours des déficits
alors les maires de famille l'équipe
financier sur les les maires de famille
les retraites des femmes est-ce que
c'était l'angle mort de cette réforme
avec sa Germain
en tout cas ça a été oui c'est possible
je suis plus cash
oui parce que ça a été en plus
communiqué de façon un peu un peu
erratique et vous voyez de façon plus
générale ce qui manque certainement et
ça vaut pour tout très fort je trouve
qu'à force de
garder en fait au lieu d'avoir un prisme
d'ensemble d'expliquer calmement
pourquoi on doit le faire quelles sont
les pistes éventuellement envisageables
le temps qui est contraint parce que si
on fait une réforme c'est pas juste pour
le principe de faire une réforme on est
dans une période d'incertitude extrême
où il y a je fais une petite un cartable
mais je crois que c'est important on
attend ça aussi des politiques
vous avez aujourd'hui des des décisions
très structurantes en matière de défense
par exemple qui doivent être prises avec
des augmentations considérables de
budget c'est aussi ça fait partie d'un
bon débat posé de dire voilà on pourrait
faire un effort de là parce qu'on a
besoin d'avoir cette stratégie on a
besoin d'avoir cette souveraineté dans
un monde qui est un peu plus complexe
qu'il y a deux ans encore donc à force
de faire cela au lieu de faire cela on a
plutôt pris par des prismes extrêmement
dédiés donc on va on va avoir un focus
sur les seniors on est peut-être passé
un peu à côté un débat plus large on va
avoir un angle mort sur les femmes
effectivement et on perd la vision
d'ensemble du pourquoi du comment et à
quelle échéance on pourrait faire et
puis on va conclure avec vous Benjamin
Morel sur l'autre aspect de ce que
disait on est au taillot l'équilibre
financier
le problème c'est que cet argument j'ai
l'impression qu'ils pèse plus dans
l'opinion quoi
vous parliez de la défense et on annonce
400 milliards sur X années enfin on sort
de deux ans et quelques de quoi qu'il en
coûte ça continue contrainte forcés par
l'inflation bref l'argument il pèse pas
quoi vous avez tout dit c'est
aujourd'hui une audible à tort ou à
raison je comprends en train de prendre
parti sur les réseaux sur les questions
de finance publique mais aujourd'hui
quand vous prenez les préoccupations des
Français très clairement les finances
publiques sont au fond du trou et qui
plus est ben les milliards que l'on
évoque ont été dépensés quasiment chaque
mois lors du confinement donc c'est pas
audible après les lignes rouges de Bruno
Retailleau entre guillemets il faut les
il faut les lire c'est à dire que ben
c'est la droite LR qui a la main au
Sénat le gouvernement pourra dire ce
qu'il veut le texte qui en suffira sera
le texte de la droite LR donc ce faisant
et bien les lignes rouges c'est lui qui
les fixe aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat Benjamin Moret je rappelle le
titre de votre livre la France en miette
livre qui est publiée aux Éditions du
Cerf je vous dis à lundi évidemment la
prochaine continue de se mobiliser tout
le week-end avec des débats en direct
également sur public sena.fr et puis
dans nos émissions d'ailleurs le
prochain rendez-vous dans la matinale
c'est Patrick Kanner dont on a beaucoup
parlé aussi sur ce plateau il sera face
à Oriane Mancini à 8h dans bonjour chez
vous belle fin de soirée
[Musique]